as far as our limited capacities are
concerned the sun is essentially an
infinite and renewable energy source
it's like a giant Fusion reactor
millions of miles away Illuminating the
Earth with as much energy as the whole
of human civilization uses in a year so
why aren't we making more use of such a
boundless source to solve all our energy
related problems well we're actually
pretty close to getting there and in
today's video I will show you how what
is solar technology anyway before I let
you in on the secret that could change
the entire world's energy consumption in
a few decades let's have a look at how
solar panels work in the first place two
main types of solar energy Technologies
are photovoltaics and concentrating
solar thermal power while both come with
their own set of pros and cons
photovoltaic systems are considerably
cheaper and thus the most widely
deployed solar electric technology in
the world currently only two percent of
the world's electricity comes from solar
power ninety percent of which is
generated from photovoltaic systems
crystalline silicon-based photovoltaic
system are the most dominant material
technology among those now silicon is an
excellent material found abundantly on
Earth with tons of properties that have
benefited Humanity over the years but it
has its fair share of drawbacks
preventing it from being an absolute
go-to semiconductor to solve all our
energy needs most of its cons are
related to efficiency manufacturing
complexity and pollution so researchers
have no choice but to limit its use on a
large scale but wait what if I told you
there's a material so efficient that it
has the potential to replace all
silicon-based photovoltaic systems in a
few years a lightweight material that's
relatively much simpler to produce at a
substantially cheaper cost a solution
that can be used to make a photovoltaic
cell so thin that only a tiny amount of
it can be used to power an entire
building well that's what the scientists
are calling solar 3.0 technology and it
is a material called pair of skites
Swift solar leaders in periscuit solar
technology in order to understand how
this revolutionary solar technology
works first let's take a look at what
Joel Gene the CEO of Swift solar one of
the most prominent teams working on pair
of Skype solar technology has to say a
new kind of thin film technology so
you've probably heard of that for for a
long time different kinds of thin films
have come and gone over the years what
we do here is a new kind of material
it's called perovskates new
semiconductor material that absorbs
light really effectively also transports
charge so it's it just turns out to be
very efficient material for solar cells
so the idea is basically to use pair of
skites to develop thin film cells in a
way that maximizes energy utility and
minimizes wastage unlike crystalline
silicon-based photovoltaic systems that
are fabricated on semiconducting Wafers
these thin film cells are developed by
depositing thin layers of semiconducting
films onto a glass plastic or metal
substrate the best part about them and
one of the underlying reasons behind
their efficiency is that these thin film
cells use 10 to A Thousand Times less
material than conventional semiconductor
Wafers used in photovoltaic systems
today multiple other materials have been
used over the years to make thin film
cells including amorphous silicon and
cadmium Telluride but now with the
introduction of pair of skites most
researchers have shifted their focus to
this leading Contender so what exactly
makes pair of skites so useful anyway
why are scientists hopeful about solar
panels with a hundred times the power to
weight performance compared to
Conventional silicon panels
effectiveness of periscuits the answer
lies in the crystal structure of
tariff's guide itself chemically
speaking pair of skites are basically
calcium titanium oxide minerals composed
of calcium titanate these occur in
nature but the interesting part is that
pair of skites used in solar cells don't
necessarily need to be mined from the
Earth's surface instead any material
with a crystal structure following the
formula abx3 can be used as a pair of
skite where A and B are two positively
charged ions arranged along with X and
negatively charged ion now without
getting too technical this basic
structure of the periscite crystal can
be replicated using a wide variety of
Elements and Minerals that would share
the same conductive properties so it
wasn't the discovery of periscuit itself
that revolutionized solar technology
instead it was when scientists realized
that they could create a wide range of
artificial pair of Skype crystals
following the same exact Crystal
Arrangement and generate immensely
useful properties out of them in fact
even common lab chemicals like metal
halide salts lead iodide or some organic
salts can be combined to make these
inorganic organic hybrid pair of Skype
crystals you can form them in a solution
or alternatively in a vacuum in
vaporform which can later be condensed
the thin films of these crystals are
also multi-layered resulting in them
being excellent semiconductors so now
that you know the basic structure of a
pair of Skype solar cell the question is
just how efficient are they our pair of
skite sells really the Holy Grail of
solar technology like scientists have
deemed them to be and if so why aren't
we manufacturing them on a larger scale
and harnessing the sun's energy to its
full potential to understand why pair of
skites hold a fundamental advantage over
silicon solar cells that we're used to
seeing let's dive a little deeper into
how photovoltaic cells convert sunlight
into electricity mechanism of a
photovoltaic cell a solar cell is made
up of two different parts a top and a
bottom both of which contain
semiconductor materials with different
electrical properties in the case of a
silicon solar cell both layers are doped
with small amounts of different elements
in order to create varying electrical
charges these two portions one of which
contains a higher concentration free
negatively charged electrons and the
other containing more positively charged
holes or missing electrons are referred
to as the n-type and p-type regions
respectively the boundary between them
is called the PN Junction when the two
layers are in contact the free electrons
and the free holes move across and
cancel each other out gradually the
electrons start filling up the holes
creating a built-in electric field this
corresponds to a voltage and the field
acts like a one-way valve for charge
barriers so when a photon the
fundamental unit of light falls on this
solar cell it immediately gets absorbed
into the cell creating an extra electron
and hole which are subsequently
separated by the electric fields and
pulled to opposite sides of the cells
and thus a photocurrent is generated
attach a pair of electrodes to both
sides of the cell forming an electric
circuit and voila you have a steady flow
of current as long as the sun shines
disadvantages of PV cells although
remarkable single Junction solar cells
are limited in their capacity and can
only absorb a restricted portion of the
solar spec primarily depending on the
semiconductor material a wide spectrum
of photons of energy that can't be
absorbed by the semiconductor material
will inevitably go to waste these
photons are usually the ones with
energies less than the band gap of the
semiconductor material you can think of
the band Gap as the lowest energy of
light that a single material can absorb
this is where perovskites truly stand
out their band gaps can easily be
changed which means you can stack pair
of slight layers on top of each other
resulting in a structure that is
chemically optimized to absorb different
parts of the solar Spectrum this level
of efficiency is particularly
interesting because it took more than 20
years of research on silicon-based solar
cells to reach the kind of efficiency
that pervskite solar cells reached in a
mere two years but that is not where the
magic ends along with the efficient
performance pair of skites have the
added advantage of being easy to
manufacture as well these thin films can
be man-made by first developing a solar
ink and gradually heating the liquid
until the material crystallizes the
entire process of man manufacturing a
pair of Skype solar cell is considerably
simpler than pretty much any other solar
technology on the market today in fact
you can synthesize these cells using
various industrial processes like spin
coating screen printing electrode
position or even by printing the
material on a sheet through an inkjet
printer researchers have recently
started combining pair of Skype solar
cells with conventional silicon solar
cells Nano textured designs or surfaces
covered with Nano size structures can
achieve a power conversion efficiency
above 29 which according to experiments
could be further improved with better
fabrication techniques limitations of
periscuits so if periscuit solar cells
are so incredible what's preventing
their mass production and integration
into all our daily lives it's worth
remembering that researchers don't play
favorites and that new technologies are
often judged holistically before
commercial production the main issue
with periscite solar cells is film
quality and thickness the material
despite its innumerable advantages
breaks down easily especially when
exposed to heat moisture snow or other
such external factors that pretty much
restricts the use of perovskite solar
cells to only certain regions where the
climate is suitable throughout the year
or on devices that you only use for a
limited period moreover the material is
highly toxic in nature so scientists
need to be extra careful with
precautionary measures When developing
periscite solar cells and they still
need to come up with processes that will
make industrial scale Productions safe
nonetheless I'm still positive that pair
of skites will increasingly be used for
commercial purposes in the near future
and that the possibility of integrated
solar panels on trucks buses and cars is
not that far-fetched in fact I'm hopeful
that we might get to see buildings or
even skyscrapers covered in transparent
photovoltaic glass windows that generate
electricity right that's it from me
today what do you think about the future
of this incredible solar 3.0 technology
let me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed watching this video don't forget
to hit the Subscribe button also if
you're interested in learning more about
everything new and the world of science
and technology check out the other
videos on the cards thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one